[Music]
is
okay let me do this please
384
i'm not sure the uniformity of
just i'm at oak park i'll put stuff
sticks here
all right going the wrong way on the
interstate
on the southbound
off-ramp
that's great
west valley road west valley drift
do you fail
negative
[Music]
celebrations
[Music]
it
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
eastbound
[Music]
[Music]
2300 archer
[Music]
northbound in the new
butler plaza
[Music]
hey pulling into the best spot
[Music]
[Music]
you bring up my vehicle
[Music]
all right we're back on arch road i am
now the lead vehicle
[Music]
oh signal 4 into a asm k9 silly mountain
blaze
hey you
good car
[Music]
all right we are at 35th boulevard still
eastbound wrong side of the road coming
up to 34th street
[Music]
people pay that truck hit that truck
trying to get to it speed 60 mile an
hour
[Music]
northbound 34th street northbound 34th
street
all right start today and i'm calling it
northbound through when moto sullivan on
34th street
[Music]
trying to get up to a pit
[Music]
[Music]
continuing on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we
[Music]
to 34th street
[Music]
again coming back out on the 34th street
southbound
hi everybody
[Applause]
y'all